go back to your first film why men cheat
in 2005 so how did that movies success
impact you getting your next film
project off the ground yeah so it was it
was a it was a while my first time that
ever that I ever got distribution for
was a film called black butterfly it was
a film we made for less than $10,000 and
he won actually put that film out we
know Eva is a major major company but a
guy named Ellen Blackwell was he solved
the trailer I said from the train he
said I want this film but before then we
did we did a film called again my first
film why men cheat I used to love her
highlight you hit me with those films
those films are the films that you know
from why men cheat we took that money
and we invested in the to holler if you
hear me we take that money investments I
used to love her and we did I used to
love her that feeling right there is
screening that we did that film for
$3,500 and it was in like 10 film
festivals and when I went to the film
festivals I didn't just go there just
the screening film when I would go to
our house DVDs made up I wasn't even
thinking about honestly I wasn't even
thinking about distribution I was just
thinking about selling DVDs and it
wasn't until we came and did black
butterfly is when you know I said okay
if I have to if I have to release this
film on my own then I would do that but
what we did was we are we are I said the
trailer - I said the trailer - Ellen
black well ie one he said I want that
family and then from that film then we
got distribution for how let you hear me
then we got because of the success that
I found and so what happened was with
black butterfly is e1 bit like the first
week they had to reprint
they threw up we had to print more DVDs
up because they all sold out in the
stores it was in Walmart and they all
sold out so they had to rush and print
more out because I told her I was like
look I have an audience out there and
what we're going to do is we want to
promote this man we're going to promote
this film so you all have to print out
more
they print out 5,000 copies the first
time which I understand I mean they want
to be safe and so like the first like
the first week or so those were all gone
and there because of the success of
black butterfly is is when we got
distribution for I used to love her then
we got distribution for all of you hit
me and from from the success of that one
fail it's so you made it for $10,000
oh one that was in Walmart yes it was it
was like the 9500 and how many locations
did you have we had a total of I think
like eight locations
yeah a location but this this is how we
were doing we were shoot the way we
shoot this film when we shoot on
weekends because people work so we were
shooting on weekends
Luis Walden we would take one day so we
would shoot a 12-hour day on a Saturday
and Sunday I'm gonna Friday when we
would deal with this when we just take
one thing and we just shoot that thing
and we just you know and that's how we
got to film a oh like a six it was like
six weeks and uh yeah so that's how you
were able to keep it solo that's what we
were able to keep it solo and also this
is the secret the secret is you have to
work with you have to work with I know
it is difficult in LA because we talk
about locations because people are
familiar with how much is you how much
money they pay people pay for locations
when Chicago is pretty different
so in Chicago for us is that you know I
always shoot out like a lot of the film
was shot at my mom's house I shot some
of this film at my aunties house you
know and a lot of the stuff we a lot of
exterior stuff you know where we don't
need we don't need any permits to set up
or we would go to a park and shoot like
the park that we shot that is a park
that I grew up in like playing
basketball and baseball and things like
that so we would go to that Park and we
shoot things so we didn't really pay a
lot of money for locations at all
because we use friends and families
locations and that's another thing we
should do you know just look at your
friends I should friends as far as like
you know can you cheat at their home you
know and try to do it you like say for
instance if you shoot at someone's home
you know just be respectful of the home
maybe donate you know donate $100 $150
towards the electricity you know and I
know in LA is kind of expensive in
locations they are very expensive but
you know just like give you shooting
somewhere else you know just ask the
person if you can just you know shoot
there you know and they open to it